todo comenzó con un asaltante que empezó
a caminar con una arma automática por la
entrada principal de la escuela
inmediatamente abrió fuego contra la
gente que tenía delante la policía rusa
acordonó a la zona y ya a esa hora
empezaban a compartirse en redes
sociales rusas vídeos de niños saltando
por la ventana y otras escenas de pánico
un atacante ha sido detenido se trata de
un joven de 19 años que estudió en el
pasado en esa misma escuela las armas
estaban registradas a su nombre los
niños evacuados de la escuela de cazando
han tenido lugar este tiroteo han sido
reubicados en escuelas infantiles
cercanas y se les está brindando
asistencia psicológica a ellos y también
a los familiares antes del asalto a la
escuela el atacante se abrió un canal en
la red social de telegram y dejó allí
varios mensajes se fotografió delante de
un espejo con una inscripción en la que
pone dios y anunció que iba a causar una
matanza y que después se iba a pegar un
tiro